salut se voir sur twitter vous me tagué
sur des liens vers des sites ou des
vidéos et très récemment l'un d'entre
vous mais envoyer un truc qui s'appelle
13 truc sic aux logiques qui te rendront
la vie plus facile je me suis dit ça
valait le coup de les lire de les
analyser de les commenter avec vous
générez
[Musique]
il ya très espèce de vérité qui sont
mises sur cet article je vais les
détails et une par une et puis je vous
donnais mon habitude merci à la personne
qui m'a envoyé le tout et si vous me
suivez pas sur twitter vous avez le lien
dans la description et twitter c'est
vraiment pas mal pour garder le contact
ensemble pour savoir si tu plat
quelqu'un choisit un mot et chaque fois
que ton interlocuteur le prononce ou
utilise une expression similaire
h la tête et sourit si tu lui plaît tu
l'a vite remarquer que cette personne va
se mettre à utiliser ce mot beaucoup
plus souvent
oui pourquoi pas mais ça voudrait dire
que cette personne est aussi dans une
démarche d' analyse et de manipulations
positif pour essayer de te plaire et
puis j'y croit qu'à moitié quoi comment
ça se passe si mon mot clé ses
courgettes flore que j'utilise
courgettes toutes les deux secondes je
pense qu'à chaque fois que j'utiliserai
courgettes jeu plairait beaucoup moins
la personne si tu veux que les gens se
prennent au sérieux dis leur que c'est
ce que te disait ton père les gens ont
une tendance à consciente à faire
confiance au conseil paternel
alors c'est même plus large que ça c'est
ce qu'on appelle le storytelling qui est
très utilisé par exemple en marketing et
dans d'autres techniques d'influencé
effectivement on est beaucoup plus
touchée par une histoire personnelle que
par une statistique ou un fait avéré ou
un discours prononcé de manière un petit
peu universitaire le storytelling c'est
l'expérience et les émotions et
effectivement ça marche beaucoup plus
pour convaincre soit imbattable à pierre
feuille ciseaux en posant une question
quelconque à ton adversaire juste avant
de jouer dans la plupart des cas les
jouets a pris de court choisiront les
ciseaux ben non c'est pas vrai on n'en
sait rien je pense que ça s'est mis
complètement au hasard
j'ai fait une vidéo sur le pierre
feuille ciseaux elle est basée sur des
études qui ont été faites et je vous
invite à regarder la vidéo que je vous
mets là quelque part mais la ddt comme
ça d'instinct je dirais non
pourquoi et puis je me vois mal à chaque
fois avant de jouer poser une question
ça va se voir un petit peu si tu veux
que ton interlocuteur soit d'accord avec
toi n'oublie pas de hocher la tête
lorsque lui pose une question c'est pas
faux est ce que t'as pas compris c'est
pas faux parce qu'il ya une sorte de
mimétisme en fait et le fait de faire un
mouvement de huy soi même influence
toutes proportions gardées le côté vrai
de la réponse qu'il faut donner c'est
une sorte de réponse sociale en fait ils
lundi oui moi aussi je veux dire oui
s'ils pensent non je suis répondre n'as
tu jamais rêvé d'un arrêt de bus et
d'une station de métro totalement vide à
8 heures du matin
non c'est pas mon rêve premier pour
traverser une foule regardant la
direction du tout mouvement tu seras
surpris de voir la foule s'écarte et
pour te laisser le passage dans les
endroits très fréquentés les gens
regardent les yeux des autres afin
d'anticiper râble déplacement ne pas
gêner alors ça c'est vrai dans les
endroits fréquentés les gens se check
inconsciemment le regard de l'autre pour
s'éviter etc
mais ça c'est normal de là a dit
il suffit de regarder bien droit devant
soi est tracé je l'essayé ça la station
de métro à côté de chez moi je suis pas
persuadé que ça donne morizet la mer
rouge donc si une chanson te trotte dans
la tête et qu'il n'arrive pas t'en
débarrasser rappelle-toi de la fin
suivant les faits diack ganic notre
cerveau se souvient mieux des tâches non
achevée par conséquent si tu penses à la
façon dont se termine la chanson qui
aura plus de chance de la faire
disparaître
alors ça c'est vrai notre cerveau est
programmé pour mieux mémoriser une
tâches inachevées ou interrompu puis de
taches achevé là c'est une petite mise
en situation rigolote qui vous propose
mais dans le fond c'est vrai si vous
aller jusqu'au bout de la tâche c'est à
dire jusqu'à chanter la chanson en
entier loup l'écouté en lâchant pas en
entier j'aurai plus de facilité à vous
en débarrasser tu veux que les enfants
mangent du brocoli tour chelou cette
question tu veux vraiment que tes
enfants qui mangent du brocoli mais au
lieu de leur demander s'ils en vrai le
demande l'heure combien tu dois leur en
servir quatre ou cinq de cette façon tu
as déjà décidé de la randonnée oui c'est
une petite techniques de manipulation on
avait vu ça aussi l'année dernière sur
la chaîne avait techniques de
manipulation donner l'impression que la
décision leur appartient au départ donc
pour ça on pose des faits établis le
fait établi c'est qu'ils vont manger des
brocolis mais par contre c'est eux qui
ont le pouvoir
ils ont le pouvoir de choisir combien et
en les concentrant là dessus sur ce
sentiment de liberté là eh bien on va le
leur a posé quelque chose si tu penses
que quelqu'un tu espionne contente toi
de bail et de regarder les personnes qui
tentent tour à cause des facteurs
comptage et du bâillement tu seras avec
certitude qui est en train d'observer
vrai c'est assez marrant de la manière
dont ils ont d'abord des ces points là
mais dans le fond ça aussi c'est vrai
pourquoi c'est vrai mais je vais vous le
dire pourquoi ça s'appelle les coquines
esi du bâillement dans notre cerveau ya
quelque chose qu'on appelle les neurones
miroirs comme son nom l'indiqué ces
neurones la réagissent à ceux qui le
voient ce sont ces neurones là qui nous
permettent d'apprendre des choses par
mimétisme et qui nous permettent aussi
l'empathie de détecter que quelqu'un est
pas bien et nous aussi on se sent pas
bien
maintenant pour ce qui est de
l'espionnage c'est un petit peu exagéré
parce qu'il suffit que la personne elle
vous est dans le champ de vision pour
que notre miroir fasse son travail et
que la personne by aussi j'veux pas
certain qu'on a besoin de ça dans les
services secrets ton interlocuteur cadre
à porter n'importe quoi par exemple un
sac si en lui passant tu continues à la
conversation c'est ni plus ni moins un
détournement d'attention psychologique
en fait on n'est pas concentré sur ça
sur cette action là on est pris par une
conversation on accepte le truc qu'on
oublie c'est vrai en partie sa marche
sera sûrement pas à 100% mais bon en
général si tu demandes à un poste de
télé dit oui aussi si tu t'apprêtes à
serrer la main de quelqu'un sur toi que
tes mains sont bien chaude les mains
chaudes sont associés à l'amabilité
bruit ça paraît logique
nex reformule ce qu'a dit mon
interlocuteur et répète
il a vraiment l'impression que tu
l'écoutés surtout que tu me comprends
alors oui ça tout à fait je vais pas
développer ce que ça aussi je l'ait déjà
développé sur la chaîne dans une vidéo
qui s'appelle aborder une personne pour
la première fois et l'idée de cette
vidéo c'était pas forcément en séduction
qui tu veux que l'on tête comment sa
requête en disant j'ai besoin de ton
aide les gens n'aiment pas se sentir
coupable oui alors pas forcément parce
que ça peut aussi mettre une grande
alerte et préparer la personne à un
refus je ne suis pas d'accord avec ce
principe tu sembles d'une paix par
quelqu'un devant lui un stylo à côté les
gens n'aiment pas aidé et ceux qui ne
leur plaisent pas mais d'un autre côté
si une route est trop insignifiant pour
être refusée de cette façon là personne
s'auto convaincre à qu'après tout
l'unité plaît pas tant que ça oui alors
c'est un raccourci là c'est vraiment
l'idée principale je pense qu'ils ont
voulu mettre derrière ça en tout cas
j'espère que c'est ça c'est de vouloir
créer des interactions simple non
engageantes avec une personne tierce qui
a du mal avec vous et c'est vrai que ça
aide à passer les premiers à priori et
si on arrive à créer comme ça des
interactions simple on va commencer à
créer un début de complicité un tout
petit début mais ça permettra d'aller
plus loin il était plutôt bien fait ce
petit article n'hésitez pas continuer à
me tailler dans des trucs sur twitter
que voulait me faire partager je passe
toujours voir n'oubliez pas de noter que
ce dimanche 23 ont fait le live sur la
chaîne à 17h30 je sais c'est le jour des
élections mais justement à 17h30 en
attendant les résultats ça changera les
idées de tout le monde donc ça hexabyte
concernant le concours énigme pour
gagner ce que vous savez si vous savez
pas c'est toujours expliqué dans cette
vidéo il ya encore un indice dans cette
vidéo pour prendre de l'avancé mais
fabien à quoi ça sert tous ces indices
d'énigmes qu'on a avant la vidéo en
question comme viens de vous dire ça
vous servir à apprendre de la vence le
jour où on va sortir la vidéo concours
et les croyez moi de l'avant s'il vous
en falloir dans cette vidéo se cache une
phrase entière une phrase clé qu'on l'a
trouvé il faudra en montrer plus que
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
le premier mot de cette phrase commence
à l'alternance à très bientôt dans le
futur ciao
[Musique]